[Applaudissements]
avant de commencer ce que vous êtes
chaude pour cette interview shy'm hec
complètement chaude shy'm vous allez
bientôt partir en tournée oh oui c'est
bon les tournées ce qui est vous voit
moqué tu fais là qu'est ce qui va vous
manquer le plus quand vous serez sur la
route
pas grand chose depuis un an avant soit
sexy le oui non oui elle va partir sur
la route à j'espère qu'elle va croiser
blake n
pour votre avenir au médiatique
oui en plus de chanteuse vous voyez
plutôt juré de danse avec les stars au
coach dans the voice l'émission il faut
savoir se retourner au bon moment intime
je préférerai danse avec les stars entre
la rumba est la samba ya beaucoup de
danse est très chaude aussi très sexy
j'avais la rumba sait tous ici ah oui
oui j'ai des tétons de partir au matin
le mister haute et or